new controversy with White House press
secretary and belligerent owl Sean
Spicer that forehead is taking up a lot
of face real estate so honestly I think
you just rent this out as a
double-decker tour bus like right up
there look at that come on true that is
hop-on hop-off papa
slicers been open with public about his
passwords gum intake and opinion on
dippin dots which is not the ice cream
of the future he says it's not basically
everything except factual information so
now he's given the american people more
access to his venmo account twitter
quickly found his public venmo profile
at Sean Spicer and bombarded him with
payment requests for things like anxiety
meds because your boss is a lunatic or
meeting with the gays to buy him new
suits but if anyone deserves this minor
inconvenience it's the alternative fact
spouting forehead known as Sean Spicer
now we would never ever tell you our
audience to do such a thing ever so
don't do this but if you requested money
from mr. Spicer screengrab it and send
it to us maybe we would feature it on
the show now I'm not saying do that in
fact I'm telling you not to
and in my deposition the record will
show I told you do not do that so
comedians what would you ask Sean Spicer
to pay for on venmo okay a plate a knife
and a fork for how often he SD all right
boys yes 50 bucks so he can drill a hole
in the wall of a truckstop bathroom for
none of your f---ing set gum removal
surgery I'm worried about him he's gross
yeah